so it's today and you want to build up a
following from scratch what are the
first three things you would do oh great
question what's up hot breath averse if
you are looking to build a social media
following from scratch while quarantined
this is the video for you i'm comedian
Joel Byers
that is my dog Guinness and this is the
hot breath podcast the show where you
learn comedy from the pros today we are
diving headfirst into social media
marketing with expert Zach Lyman who's
generated millions of dollars for
companies and spoken at several events
on the topic stay tuned till the end for
an extra bonus tip so carly asks so it's
today and you want to build up a
following from scratch what are the
first three things you would do oh great
question this question okay I would
first establish how much money I can
spend fifty dollars of five dollars is
it and then that would lead me into what
do I like what apps do I already like
right I am a big fan of Instagram
already okay I love I'm on Instagram
anyways so I would be like okay I'm
gonna pick Instagram I have $10 to spend
great and then I would decide what am i
posting am I missing am i gonna post
videos pictures do I have a show idea
that I could do on Instagram in 30
seconds or whatever okay and then I so I
would figure out Instagram I'm gonna
make weekly videos and I'm gonna spend
ten dollars a month and these videos are
gonna be this type of comedy so I'm
gonna follow I'm gonna follow a bunch of
counts that I like or follow a bunch of
counselor may be doing the same thing to
give me inspiring sergeant in my page
I'm forced to look at people doing what
I want to do
and then what else what I do I would
probably then just start looking deep
into hashtags okay I I'm a huge fan of
like like for me like I am I already
know marketing but I am constantly
watching webinars YouTube anytime like
even when I worked at a company and I
would get phone calls where marketing
companies would call me and say that
they can do their mark my marketing
better right I would sit in on their our
call of them telling me what they're
gonna do and so I'm always like teach me
teach me when I'm you're gonna do and
now I can apply that and so whatever
video I want to do like if I already
know how to write sketch comedy I'm
still gonna go to youtube and type in
how to write sketch comedy and just
watching what people are making how
they're doing different things and so I
would be constantly learning about the
thing that I want to post on Instagram
hmm and then I would be telling everyone
about it I think that's a very important
key is telling all your friends that
you're doing it and that reminding them
they're like I'm doing it tomorrow I'm
making it tomorrow
I made it today yesterday I made it and
constantly be reminding people that
that's what you do that's your thing and
I would just like out deep dive into
especially right now with all this free
time right I'll be making like if I
wanted to make 10 second jokes again
right now I'll be making five ten
seconds oakes a day if possible 10 SEC's
you know I make like crazy lists for
myself to-do lists and just be knocking
that out and I'll be creating all kinds
of content and then it goes back to just
like joke writing where it's like you
write ten jokes and then you go and
you're like I'm really only gonna use
this one right and so I would be
creating a bunch of content for
Instagram and then being like no only
these five I'll post and then you're
just setting a different bar with your
quality that's what I have the question
yeah yeah these are great you actually
gave us more than three but I mean these
are all great tips and it is I have
heard like batch recording as I'm I'm
going deep onto YouTube now when you're
talking to
out one of your great tips was like
think about where you want to post
because it's like you can post on every
platform like averagely or you can pick
one that you're really passionate that's
really intuitive to you and just produce
quality content on there so yeah that's
that that's super valuable
thanks for watching hot breath averse
this video is from a Q&A in our private
Facebook group go in the description to
join us there or click the video next to
my head to hear even more social media
tips